en ile de france 11 10 sont
officiellement déclarés pour les
élections régionales
parmi elles quatre sont moins connus
sandro râteau et la tête de liste aux
élections j pour les yvelines mené par
le parti écologiste et antispécistes
révolution écologique pour le vivant
sajid évidemment de de mettre en
évidence le fait que les idées que nous
portons pour une écologie radicale ou
sociales antispécistes ont déjà refusé
au sein de la société civile ce que nous
voulons maintenant c'est les porter dans
le débat sur la scène politique
donc c'est l'idée si vous voulez d'une
écologie qui ne soit plus centré sur
l'humain mais qui insiste sur l'idée que
les autres êtres vivants ne sont pas des
ressources à notre disposition mais
possède une valeur en eux mêmes parmi
les idées fortes la création d'une
maison régionale des animaux ou encore
la suppression des subventions allouées
aux chasseurs autres listes autre
objectif ile-de-france il d'europe est
porté par elvire ces cas dans les
yvelines ile-de-france il d'europe est
un peu un regroupement on va dire de
c'est une volonté du déclencheur
renouvellement politique la liste
mobilise plusieurs mouvements là c'est
des mouvements citoyens principalement
et pro-européen donc et puis aussi les
manques de la société civile comme voir
les candidats souhaitent la mise en
place du rich et de la convention
citoyenne régionales mais ils veulent
aussi créer des maisons de la
parentalité et des femmes
autre mesure la création de parkings
gratuits à proximité des gares
franciliennes agir pour ne plus subir
c'est le nom de la liste conduite par
l'union des démocrates musulmans
français dans les yvelines c'est aïcha
ia qui est tête de liste
objectif donner la voix aux musulmans et
non musulmans qui ne se retrouvent plus
dans les partis traditionnels lutter
contre l'islamophobie mais aussi réduire
les déserts médicaux
marc de fouquières lui est tête de liste
yvelines pour france démocratie directe
une liste citoyenne qui permet à chacun
de s'exprimer de proposer des projets et
des idées
l'objectif lutter contre le manque de
transparence et redevenir acteur de la
démocratie